hi everybody I hope you're enjoying the
conference so far it's been great I've
never spoken to an audience of fish
before so that's the first it's pretty
awesome so I I'm gonna introduce myself
briefly a bit as well I'm Lia I if
you've ever heard my name before it's
probably due to one of my open source
projects you can find them on github or
my website the most popular of which are
prism J s doublet prefix-free and css3
test comm you're gonna see some of them
in my talk I'm also like cami mentioned
I'm an invited expert in the CSS working
group I used to work for w3c in the past
and these days I'm writing my first book
for O'Reilly which is going to be called
CSS secrets and it's gonna be it's gonna
be released in 2014 so if you like this
talk look out for it so I'm well aware
that this is a JavaScript conference and
I love JavaScript don't get me wrong but
this this talk is more about how you
don't need to use JavaScript for
everything because sometimes it's it
results to more maintainable code and
less code to use CSS for some things one
of those things is transitions and
animations so in the olden days which is
for some people it's still the present
when when we used CSS to change
something the transitions were abrupt
for example here when I hover over this
button its background changes and also
something appears you can see the
relevant CSS code on the side and you
can see that there's no transition
everything just magically appears out of
nowhere this is bad user experience we
might not notice it because we're used
to understanding how stuff works but for
people that aren't as used to computers
as much as we are it might be very
confusing for example my favorite
example of this is the the the
minimizing effect that OSX has if you've
ever used Mac OS you're probably
familiar with it he'll when you minimize
a window it does this effect before it
disappears it
just magically disappear out of the
screen the reason this happens is that
it's not just Apple's way of showing us
that they're cool and they can do nice
animations it actually serves a purpose
for people that aren't very tech savvy
it shows them where the window went we
might not often think about that because
obviously we know where the window when
it's on the dock we can find it it's
pretty obvious stuff right but it's not
obvious for everybody so this helps
people that aren't as accustomed to
using new eyes to know where where it
went on how to bring it back of course
sometimes delays are even worse I'm not
saying you should after this talk you
should go to every CSS code you've
written not tons of transitions that's
horrible it's even worse especially for
advanced users if you are delaying them
with the transition that serves no
purpose because they know what's going
on it's it's much worse than everything
being abrupt for example when I'm the
text editor I like to use is called
espresso not many people use it but I
kind of like it so even though it has
lots of nice features there is something
that really bothers me when you press
command and L to go to a specific line
in your code there is this very long
animation for the window to appear that
lets you type here the line you want to
go to that really bugs me every time it
bugs me so much that I end up not even
using this feature just manually looking
for the line of code I want to go there
because usually when you want to go to a
specific line of code you don't want to
go you don't just sit around thinking oh
I gonna go to line 120 I think it's a
cool line usually it's because you're
debugging something you saw an error
message type error or not on line 120
and you're frustrated what the hell did
I screw up this time so you're gonna go
there and see what what what what went
wrong you don't want to be delayed with
animations you know where the window
came out from you know what's going on
you're a developer for [ __ ] sake so
yeah don't piss off your users you
should you should take it on a
case-by-case basis do I need to use a
transition here would it help it's
always a trade-off it's a trade-off
between the
and making your UI more understandable
and the more advanced your users the
less transitions you should probably use
and the or the or the quickest you
should make them anyway so let's assume
we want to animate the background color
of an element in the past we would
probably include like a huge library for
example jQuery and sometimes we might
even need to include an extra plugin and
then we would have to write JavaScript
to do something like this this is just
an example I know it could be done
better so in this case we've included a
total of 93 kilobytes minified for now
just to do a transition how many of you
have included a library any like any
JavaScript library in your page just to
be able to do transitions or animations
be honest
so this is pretty horrible we don't
really need to do this anymore because
we have CSS transitions now so I'm not
gonna dwell on the basics but for
example in this in this very simple
example you have a button it changes its
color when you hover over it and it
happens abruptly like CSS 2.1 used to be
if the the the way to use a very very
simple transition is to write something
like this this tells the browser any
property you can possibly transition
please transition it and make it last
one second so now when I hover over it
or out of it it happens smoothly and it
takes one second you can even have
different transitions on the hover State
for example if I specify zero seconds
here when I hover all the button it
happens immediately but when I hover out
of it it happens smoothly this might be
useful for example when you want to do
something and the user is in a rush and
you don't want to delay them with fancy
transitions but when on the out state
you have more time to do a nice
transition so this is like the simplest
possible way to do a CSS transition but
before I move on to other examples I
know what many of you are thinking yeah
this is cool stuff but come on I can't
use it yet because come on won't
somebody think of the browsers the
browser support for this is terrible I
can't use it in my projects today so
let's get this out of the way first
because I don't want you to be thinking
about this throughout my talk I want you
to be focusing on the code so this is
the browser support for transitions and
animations today basically they're
supported by almost every browser in use
today except I 9 and below this means
that worldwide at least I know in Asia
the the numbers are slightly worse but
worldwide this is about 80% of your
users
and I know you might be thinking what
about the the other 20% I don't want my
website to break for one out of five
people well the thing is these features
are designed in such a way that your
website won't break for the right foot
for the people who use old browsers
there just won't be an effect there just
won't be a transition it won't be as
easy to use but it will still work
everything will would still work if you
write your code properly if you if you
write your code with graceful
degradation in mind this shouldn't be a
problem and the time you save by doing
it with CSS transitions and animations
instead of JavaScript and the way your
code is is much more organized because
the style isn't in the CSS file it's not
scattered around your JavaScript I think
I think it makes it worth it so here's
another example there's a div when I'm
pressing my keyboard arrows it grows
because this transition is applied to it
it's a very simple transition that I
showed earlier so this is that the the
HTML CSS code looks like this obviously
the CSS code is a bit longer than this
but this is the parts you should be
concerned about it's just the day of a
class of light box it has a width and
height of 0 and when I press my keyboard
arrow keys I apply a class of current
which makes it grow so as the class
lightbox should probably gives away this
is not the kind of transition I wanted I
wanted the transition that looks like
these like box galleries where you have
when the image grows vertically and then
it grows horizontally and then when it
shrinks it does it the reverse wait
first shrinks horizontally and then
vertically so is this the only kind of
CSS transition you can you can do
everything happening at the same time
because we don't want this we want the
width to be first and the height to be
second so that we sequence those
transitions and we create this very
popular lightbox effect it turns out you
can't do this with CSS but you first I
first need to tell you three more things
about CSS transitions that might seem
useless the first you might seem useless
but they become really useful when I try
to do when I tell you the the third
one that binds it all together the first
thing is you can constrain transitions
by CSS property if I specify a CSS
property here only that property will be
transitioned so here when I do this when
I press my keyboard arrow keys again
it's only to hide the transition
smoothly the width judge just just jumps
to the ankle abruptly like in CSS 2.1
the second thing i wanted to show you is
transition delays if I specify a second
time value here for example one second
the transition will take one second to
start it becomes more clear if I specify
property as well so here as you can see
the width jumps immediately to the end
value but the height takes one second to
start transitioning and you might be
wondering why why would I need to do
this but both of these features become
much more useful if you if I if I tell
you that you can use multiple
transitions with different parameters if
you separate them by commas
so I can use I can specify a 1 second
width transition followed by a 1 second
high transition that weights 1 second
before it starts and if you think about
it what this does is that the width will
kick in immediately the width transition
will start immediately after I press
make here my keyboard arrow but the high
transition will wait one second which
means the width will have finished
transitioning before the height starts
which effectively makes them happen in
sequence as you can see now so this is
almost what I wanted but not quite when
it closes it's exactly what I wanted
width first height second when it opens
I wanted that the height to happen first
than the width second I wanted them to
happen in Reverse but here the width is
first in the height second in both cases
so what I need to do
is what I showed you before about
specifying different transitions for
different states so when the keyboard
when the lightbox has the class of
current I can reverse these properties
and I works the way I wanted both ways
and if I want to make the code more
drive because now if I want to change
the duration I need to change it in six
places so if I need to if I want to make
the code more dry I can just override
transition property because transition
is a shorthand and this should work the
same but now if I want to change the the
transition duration of this I only need
to change it in three places which is
half than before it's still not
perfectly dry but it's a big improvement
and also since this is a lightbox why
not add an overlay in so if you remember
the CSS code I showed earlier there's a
box shadow here
if I add
if I if I tweak the box shadow a bit by
adding another one with zero offset zero
blur and a very large spread and making
it semi trans semi-transparent black and
also adding one here with a completely
transparent color because I want the
color to transition so I need to tell
the browser that don't animate the
spread just animate the color this is
why I added this redundant shadow here
that does nothing so now which the Box
shadow doesn't animate we have an
overlay but there's no animation for it
and that's because we have specified
that we only want the width and height
to animate if we add a box shadow
transition here and here
it should also fade just like we're used
to in light boxes and we did that with
no extra elements not even pseudo
elements just a box shadow I've actually
used this effect in webplatform.org when
I was working at w3c the video that
appears here has a very very similar
transition effect it's all done with CSS
and in users using ie8 ie9
what happens is that they just see the
window immediately there's no animation
and there's no overlay big deal they can
still see the video everything works
nothing breaks just no effects here's
another common example obviously it's
simplified from what you would usually
use in a website but the idea is you
have some text and when you hover over
it some more text is revealed and that
happens because we are transitioning the
height however if I go here and add
another line you can see that line
because the height is hard-coded we
don't want the height the other height
to be hard-coded so let's specify
height:auto as you can see when I
specify height:auto it doesn't quite
work and the reason it doesn't work is
that
yeah
what's going on here the reason it
doesn't work is that for value to be
animatable
you should be possible - it should be
possible to represent all intermediate
states in CSS CSS transitions and
animations work the same way basically
as what jQuery does they take the two
states and they generate all the
intermediate frames
it just happens behind the scenes in the
browser but you should still be able to
represent them in CSS because otherwise
what if you do a get computed style
while an animation is running what do
you get back you need to be able to get
a proper CSS value back which means when
you want you animate something like a
height from 0 to 100 or whatever value
you can figure out what the intermediate
states would be same when you're doing a
transition between colors because colors
are basically still numbers they're
converted to RGB a and it's just the
numbers that are interpolated same with
transforms it's all numbers even things
like weird things like gel index can
still be animated it's just that the
intermediate states are all integers
because they only accept integers but
you can still animate them but what
happens when you have height:auto to 100
pixels
what's the intermediate stage how can
you say something that's 25% auto and
75% a hundred pixels there's no such
value or when you want to show something
by setting display from none to block
what are the intermediate states same
with an image how can you say something
that's 30% foo JPEG and 70% bar JPEG
there is a caveat here gradients
gradients are all numbers because
they're just functions with colors and
colors top positions so you would expect
that the intermediate values would be
something like this so you would expect
you'd be able to animate them however
browsers are being dicks here because
you can't really uneme gradients today
in Britain in today's browser you should
be able to eventually it wasn't the spec
and it wasn't CSS values CSS image
values 3 but it got removed because no
browser implemented it
however don't be sad because there are
lots and lots of things you can animate
in CSS I've created a gallery here you
can find it on my github with animations
with just a single property and it's
kind of impressive what you can do by
animating just one property so imagine
what you can do if you only made lots of
properties together this is my favorite
kind of makes you wonder if you're drunk
and especially if you animate transforms
you can create really interesting stuff
especially CSS transforms CSS 3d
transforms as you can see here
and even when you want to make stuff
appear even though you can't animate you
can't make it animate when you're just
doing when you're just hiding and
showing it with display:none in
display:block you can still use other
ways to hide and show things for example
if you use a transform instead actually
let me show you first that it doesn't
work just in case you don't believe me
if I do a transition of one second
still nothing but if I hide it with a
transform instead of a transition and
show it with the transform now it
animates and obviously this is not very
useful but if I set the transform origin
to be somewhere horizontally in the
center vertically at the top well I
still need to fiddle with it a little
bit maybe minus 10 pixels it's telling
you it's starting to become something
that would be more desirable obviously
you need to fiddle with it a little bit
to do exactly what you want and yes in
this case this doesn't degrade
gracefully
because if not if transitions and
animations are not supported you just
have it there at all times it doesn't
hide in it that doesn't appear so you
should use something like moderniser to
detect whether transitions and
transforms are supported and make your
and apply different CSS code in those
cases but it's still doable and the
JavaScript code you need to you need to
write in those cases is still much much
less than whether you done in cases then
if you were writing the transfer the
transitions and animations in JavaScript
as well also I told you before that you
can't do animations between images but I
kind of lied you can't do transitions
between images in CSS image values 3 it
was there but it got removed for the
same reason gradient transitions were
removed because browsers didn't
implement
but there is a new crossfade function
that does exactly what I said you can't
do before that allows you to specify
that you want an image that's 10% foo
jpg and 90% bar jpg by changing by
overlaying one image on all on another
and changing the dimensions and you
might be thinking that CSS image values
level 4 is very far from now but we've
already started getting implementations
chrome already supports this and has
been supporting this for a while and
chrome has a very huge market share work
worldwide these days and it's been
supporting this since April 2012 this is
just me animating a CSS logo you don't
even there's no crossfade function in
the code here it's just used behind the
scenes by the browser to make the
transition of course you can use it in
your CSS as well if you want here's
another cool thing you can do with
transitions so here I have a div when I
keep my mouse button pressed on it and
it gets the pseudo class of active the
background changes and the text color
changes as well just in case somebody is
colorblind and can't be can't see the
background change so if we add a simple
transition here you can imagine how that
would work
it would smoothly transition to these
colors and then smoothly back however if
you recall we can specify different
transitions so here we can specify a
transition with that lasts one second in
here a transition that lasts zero
seconds so effectively no transition but
is delayed one second what this does is
when I click on it there is a transition
it happens smoothly but when I release
my mouse button it takes a second to go
back so if I if I use like a very large
value here and you imagine what would
work what would happen there is a nice
transition when I click on it
and then it just stays there it doesn't
go back so this is effectively a way to
maintain state with CSS and in this
example it's not very useful although I
can still think of some use cases but
somebody used this to make this demo
which is a character controlled by CSS
but buttons so this is all CSS there's
no JavaScript here also you might if any
of you used flash before you might be
wondering yeah okay this is cool but
what if I want more fine-grained control
in my animation what if I want to
control how the animation progresses
from the start value to the end value so
here you can see two different ways for
that to happen the first one is the
default and the second one in the second
one it progresses linearly which means
at 30% time it will be 30% through the
transition there's no acceleration no
deceleration it just happens linearly
but you don't have to even be you don't
have to even be constrained between
those two you can get the second
behavior by specifying the keyword
linear and there are a few other
keywords like ease in which this which
speeds up towards the end there's also
ease out but these are just shorthand
for a function called cubic Bezier cubic
Bezier looks like this and it accepts
four values from zero to one usually but
not necessarily and it's almost
impossible to describe this just by
showing you the function it's much
easier to describe this graphically
because cubic Bezier corresponds to a
Bezier curve from one point to another
and the two values are the coordinates
over the first of this pole of the first
handle and the last two are the
coordinates of the second handle so this
is basically a graph of
how the transition progresses over time
the horizontal axis is time the vertical
axis is progression so if you if you do
something like this for example it means
that as time goes by it will start
moving towards the end value then it
will slowly go back and then it will
keep going towards the end value which
looks like this did you see how it
stopped in the middle went back and then
forwards and it's really useful if you
want to do bounce effects look at this
this means it goes towards the end value
really quickly then it jumps further
than the end value and then it goes back
to the end value which creates a bounce
and you can even do bounces like this
something that bounces before it starts
not at the end and this up is online at
cubic Bezier calm or you can find it at
my github but even though transitions
are pretty cool and they're a huge step
forward from what we had in CSS 2.1
they're still quite limited they can't
be fired on page load for example if you
want to have like an element fall from
the sky when the page when the user
loads the page you can't do it you can't
repeat them like three times for example
there's just a start at state and an end
state and it's just that and they can't
be about different properties for
example you can't you can't animate if
the start value and the end value is
about background you can't be animating
the color the text color as well and
this is why the gods of CSS gave us CSS
animations CSS animations are more
powerful but also more verbose more
complicated so if you can do something
with CSS transitions you should do it
with CSS transitions but if you can't it
doesn't mean you have to result to
JavaScript you can still do it sometimes
you can still do it in CSS with CSS
animations although basically everything
you can do with CSS animations you can
also do it with a combination of
JavaScript and CSS transitions so a
basic animation this is a basic
animation it has two components it
starts from this from this dark red
background then it goes to orange
halfway and then it goes to yellow green
and animations have two components one
of them is the keyframes rule that that
defines the basic state the basic States
and obviously the browser interpolates
between them as well and then you need
to use the animation function to bind
these to specify where you want to use
this transition and the animation
property did I say function I meant
property the animation property is very
similar to the transition property it
takes a time value as well here's one
second and instead of oops or instead of
a CSS property it takes the name of an
animation you've defined in this case
rainbow so you can see how our animation
happened and then it it went away and we
can see the background that we had
before so we can make it repeat by
specifying a number here let me remove
it and reapply it so now it will happen
three times and then it will stop again
and if we don't want it to ever stop we
can specify infinite and now it will
just keep on animating but I'm gonna
stop it because otherwise some people
here will get Caesar's also a 0% can be
written as from and 100% can be written
as two and you don't even use the you
don't even need to use both of them if
one of them is missing the browser will
just generate it from the normal state
so if I remove this instead of animating
from dark red the browser will animate
from the slate but gray background I
have now so let me remove the animation
and reapply it so as you can see
although I should probably make it a bit
longer it animates from the state from
its normal state towards orange and
yellow green and then it jumps back this
is another example I'm animating this
heart from a transform of none to a
scale of 120% which which makes it look
like it's pounding but it doesn't look
very smooth so one way to make it smooth
is to change this to 50% and change this
four to Frohman two and this should be
double wears cruel not applying my CSS
let me remove it and reapply it yep that
works so now it seems more smooth but
it's still unnatural and the reason it's
unnatural is because when it grows the
the timing function remember those cubic
Bezier values I showed you earlier so
when it grows it houses a certain timing
function of ease which is the default in
this case but when it shrinks the timing
function doesn't reverse it just keeps
being the same which makes it look
unnatural however there's a better way
to do this this is a simple animation
from a background of yellow to a
background of blue I can bind it by
doing something like this and specify
three iterations and because Chrome is
an idiot remove it and reapply it so as
you can see this case it goes smoothly
from yellow to blue and then it just
jumps back to yellow so that it so that
it repeats this is its progress over
time we can change this behavior by
using the property animation Direction
if we specify that an animation
direction of alternate instead of
looking like this it looks like this
which means every second iteration is
flipped it's reversed so it goes
smoothly to from yellow to blue and then
smoothly from blue to yellow so the
whole animation is smoother and if I
remove this and reapply it you can see
how it smoothly goes from blue to yellow
in every in the second animation which
makes the whole thing smoother and
there's also reverse which reverses
every single iteration and alternate
reverse which is a combination of
alternate and reverse it reverses
everything the first iteration the third
iteration so on every row decoration so
how can we take advantage of this year
if we specify the keyword alternate we
instantly made it smoother and it looks
even more natural
well I first need to make this the way
it was from and to and copy cut and
paste it
okay this was how it was in the
beginning if I specify the keyword
alternate it suddenly becomes much
smoother and I can now reduce the
duration Chrome is so annoying there
there you go just by using it keyword
this is a bit of a different example
it's a very common caveat here I have a
border animating from zero solid to 100%
solid so it's basically just the border
width animating and I've applied the
animation here but there's no border I
can't see any border I can't see any
animation and it's not because the color
is missing because the if when the color
is missing it just gets the text color
which is black I can even include the
color if you don't believe me it still
won't work
can anybody imagine why it doesn't work
it doesn't work is that border is just
the shorthand of border width border
style and border color in this case
border width and border color are
animatable so it's fine but border style
is not animatable you can't go from none
which is the default value to solid with
an animation it's just either none or
solid there's no such thing as 50% none
and 50% solid
so since border style is not animatable
its dropped from the animation it's like
it doesn't exist and since it doesn't
exist you get the default border style
which is none so if you specify a border
style here and reapply the animation so
I specified non solid
if you specify a border style of solid
here you can start seeing the animation
because the border style is not defined
in the keyframes now this behavior will
actually be changed that was a
resolution we made in the CSS working
group last year browsers haven't caught
up with it yet and actually it was this
example this example in a doublet that I
presented and made the CSS working group
changed its mind and this is a PNG file
with ten frames of an animation this is
some CSS code that applies to this div
whoops and let me show you where what
the boundaries of the d'Ivoire this is
our div it has a width of 50 pixels and
a height of 72 pixels and we want to
have a frame-by-frame animation I mean
we already have our frames here and this
div is basically functioning as a stripe
as a sprite so if we manually change
this to 50 pixels we can see a different
frame with a hundred pixels we can see
another frame - 150 pixels another frame
so if we manually change this we can see
all the different frames so we want to
do this with a CSS animation so our
naive first approach would be to write
the keyframes rule
from no to background position - 500
pixels and zero we don't need to write
the Frome rule because like I said
before it will be generated from this
value which also made makes it the great
gracefully very easily because in
browsers that don't support CSS
animations you just don't get an
animation you get the first frame and
let's tie the animation oh I didn't
specify a name wave let's tie the
animation here with our element so you
can see how this didn't go down very
well this is not a frame-by-frame
animation it's just awful and even if we
specify a linear keyword so that it
doesn't accelerate and decelerate like
this it's still weird it this is not a
key frame by frame animation so should
we give up is it impossible to do a
sprite animation in CSS should we use
JavaScript actually no because we don't
just have cubic Bezier easing functions
we also have another type of easing
functions which is steps and steps just
makes abrupt changes but lots of them
how many as many as the parameter you
specify which is very useful for frame
by frame animations and you might be
wondering why do I need another way to
create animated gifs why why is this
useful the reason this is useful is that
this way you can animate images that
have alpha transparency gifs don't have
alpha transparency so for example if you
want to have like a spinner on top of
your whatever and you don't know what
background it will be on it will be much
better to do it this way then here's an
animated gif which needs to have a
specific background color and yes there
was an image type that was supposed to
do this it was called a P&G and some
browsers do support it but you might be
surprised to hear that ap
she has worse browser support than
animations this is the program the
spinner here by the way was done this
way and this is another nice function of
steps this is a typing animation there
are two animations in play here one of
them is the typing animation which
animates the width from 0 to your final
width and this one animates the caret
here with and it makes it blink also
with with steps this is all the code
this needs and since the steps are not
hard-coded in the keyframes rule but
here you can also set them with
JavaScript and it's also using the CH
unit which many of you might not have
seen the CH unit is corresponds to the
width of the 0 character which is useful
when you have monospaced fonts like this
because the width of a 0 character is
the same as the width of every character
and in case animations are not supported
this is what people will see which still
communicates the same effect there's no
animation but the text is still legible
and it kind of looks like a console type
thing so it's not horrible
when animations are not supported it's
just better when they are and this is a
whole point about graceful degradation
this is another case and I'm running out
of time so a while back a friend of mine
Chris coiour
if you've heard him from CSS tricks came
to me and he was like how can I make an
element rotate in a circular path
without the actual air element rotating
because here it is rotating in a
circular path but the element is also
rotating as well we don't we don't want
that we just wanted to move in a
circular path so at first I thought it
couldn't be done but after a while I
came up with a solution of using two
transforms on two different elements and
having one of them cancelled
the other which would look like this I
have to reverse rotations at every at
any point the each rotation cancels the
other I have two elements a different
transform origin and a different
animation applies to each of them so one
of them cancels the other so you see no
rotation but you just see the movement
and you can make it even shorter if you
use animation direction so you can
eliminate this and instead of overriding
animation name override animation
direction which just generates this
counterclockwise animation on the fly by
using animation direction reverse and if
I remove this and reapply it you can see
that it still works with less code but
you need you still need to HTML elements
however when I when I wrote to the CSS
working group and asked them to allow
people to specify different transform
origins on the same element so you don't
need two elements to do this sort of
thing a guy called Aria Gregor wrote
back to me and she was like you couldn't
do this today it's just that the syntax
is not very intuitive and you can do it
this way by using a transform that
rotates an element then translates it by
a fixed amount and then rotates it back
by the same amount of degrees it was
rotated earlier which means the two
rotations cancel each other but you
still see the translation because the
thing with transforms is every transform
operates on the on the coordinate system
that the previous transform set they're
not independent their order matters so
the element rotates then it moves and
then it rotates back so you see the
movement but you don't see the rotation
it did take me like a few months to
understand how that worked
so as this talk is close to its end this
is pretty much what I covered so there
are still things that you you can read
about if you're interested in
transitions and animations one of them
is the animation film mode and that
specifies how your animation behaves
when it's not playing and also the
events there there are lots of events
fires like transition
and animation start things like that
that you can use in JavaScript to do
cool stuff and before I finish a short
reality check the code I showed you
looks like this but um prefix
transitions have much worse browser
support only 60% of browsers and
prefixed animations are even worse only
one out of four users will be able to
see any of unprefixed animations so even
though the code I showed you looks like
this
the actual code looks like this and yes
I know this is horrible but there are
ways to make your code more Drive one of
them is my library prefix treats pretty
short you just drop it in your page
right unprefixed CSS and it just makes
stuff work there are some alternatives
some websites you can go and put in your
code and gets prefixed there are also
pre processors where you can write make
sense but you have to write the mixin to
yourself and yes I know this is a bit
depressing so here's a picture of a
donkey laughing to cheer you up before I
leave you here are some resources you
can you don't need to write them down my
slides are in line and if you have any
questions you should find me at the
breaks because we don't have time right
now for questions Thomas is already kind
of pissed off I think so that was it I
hope you learned something thank you
very much
you